One last thing Lauren said that we're going to discuss, is the idea of
language, thought and culture together. So what happens when we learn our
native language and then we're exposed to people who speak a different
language? Will we be able to understand concepts that they have in their
language, if we don't have those in ours? Well, the Sapir-Whorf Hypothesis
states that language creates thought as much as thought creates language. And
the idea here is that if we're speaking different languages, we don't have a
common foundation. Therefore, it would be difficult to communicate and
translate ideas from one language to the other. Now the linguistic
determination hypothesis, suggest that our language actually determines our way
of thinking and our perceptions of the world. Basically, what they're saying is
that, we don't have a word for an idea or a concept in our language, it's not
possible to think about that idea or that concept. Now, one very interesting
example that seems to support this hypothesis comes from a small tribe of about
200 people who live in the Amazon area of Brazil. Now these individuals have no
words for numbers that are higher than two. Therefore it's almost impossible
for them to understand the concepts of nine and ten. And they even have
difficulty with an operation 3 plus 1. Now this is not because these people are
not intelligent. It is because they don't have words for numbers higher than
two. Now let's go back to Lauren for a recap of this section on language.